- Ça ici quand on l'a planté,
et ça pousse à une vitesse
exponentielle
- Le maire de l'arrondissement
est fier de nous montrer
les arbustes d'une de
ses micro-forêts situées
dans le parc Père-Marquette.
FRANCOIS LIMOGES, maire arron.
- Une micro-forêt, c'est un
concept qui a été développé
au Japon, qui est un concept
où l'on plante des toutes
oches les unes
des autres dans l'espoir
qu'elles se fassent compétition
très rapide pour absorber
énormément de carbone.
- L'arroager une
premiere micro-forêt urbaine
dans un parc à l'intersection
de la Côte Ste-Catherine
et de la Côte du Vésinet.
arrondissement Outremont
- Nous nous mettons ici
sur un terrain en pente.
Ça va limiter l'érosion
qui vont pousser. Aussi, ça va
créer une zone tampon avec
Côte Ste-Catherine pour le
bruit. Ça va êon,
parce qu'une mini-forêt capte
beaucouparbone,
de CO2 que des arbres
individuellement.
- La Ville investit dans
des micro-forêts, mais aussi
dans la plantation d'arbres.
L'an dernier, Montréal a planté
plus de 40 000 arbres
et souhaite que la population
CAROLINE BOURGEOIS, resp. grands
parcs, comité exécéal
entreprises, les institutions,
les citoyens qui peuvent aussi
planter dans leur cour arrière
ou leur petit lopin de terre
un arbre.
de faire face aux changements
climatiques, de contrer
les sécheresses et
ANTHONY DANIEL, biologiste
- Les arbres non seulement vont,
mais vont produire également
de l'humidité dans l'air.et metu
dans l'air. Ils vont
également nous prémunir
contre les vents très forts.
- Difficile d'être contre la
nature et la beauté des arbres,
même enner une petite
illusion... une petite illusion
d'être is.
(rires)
- Quand tu passes sur une rue
pas d'arbres, c'estttttt
laid et dégradé. Alors la nature
amène une beauté à la ville.
- Ici Jacques Biss
Radio-Canada, Mo